WILL BENEFIT THE NDEZ))
PUBLIC
EDUCATION FOUNDATION'S TEACHER
EXCHANGE PROGRAM TO SEE OFF
THANK YOU ROCKY THE LAS
VEGAS, REAL ESTATE MARKET IS
CONSTANTLY CHANGING THE
SPONSOR OF THIS NEXT SEGMENT.
PALACIOS REALTY IS HERE TO
GIVE US THE LATEST UPDATES,
WELCOME JERRY RAIN TO THE SHOW
AND JARED LET'S START OF WHAT
IS THE MARKET UPDATE FOR THIS
WEEK AND OUR HOME STILL
SELLING LIKE HOT CAKES RIGHT
NOW. WE'RE TELL YOU JESSE THAT
HOMES ARE NOT SELLING LIKE HOT
CAKES IN FACT IT WAS JUST
ANNOUNCED CASE ARE NOW SELLING
LIKE LAS VEGAS MEDIAN HOME
PRICE RIGHT NOW IS 395,000
WE'VE GOT 7.7 MONTHS OF
INVENTORY.
AND RATES ARE STILL IN THE
THREES SO THAT JUST MEANS
SELLERS CAN SELL AT A
PHENOMENAL OPPORTUNITY BUYERS
CAN ABSOLUTELY BY AND STILL
GET A GREAT HOUSE, SO THAT
THERE'S A SHORTAGE RIGHT NOW
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE SAYING YES
WHAT'S WHAT'S CAUSING THE
SHORTAGE IN THE MARKET RIGHT
SO LET'S TAKE A STEP BACK
TIME IT WAS 3 MONTHS OF
INVENTORY 6,000 UNITS AND THE
MEDIAN PRICE WAS 332,000 NOW
IF YOU'RE A BUYER. YOU COULD
HAVE GONE AND CHOPPED AND GET
ANYTHING YOU WANTED WITH VERY
LITTLE RESISTANCE RIGHT AND
LEADING INTO THAT MOMENT, WE
STILL HAD SOME OTHER ISSUES TO
DEAL WITH FOR EXAMPLE NEW HOME
CONSTRUCTION WAS ALREADY ON
THE DECLINE HAVING ISSUES WITH
THAT LEADING INTO IT. NOW YOU
ADD THE PANDEMIC RATE SELLERS
HAVE BEEN RELUCTANT TO SELL
BUYERS REALIZE, HEY I NEED TO
GET BETTER PLACE I JUST WANT
TO BE THAT SAME REALIZATION IS
AND NOW THEY'RE LOOKING AT HEY
WHERE DO I WANT TO LIVE
BECAUSE NOW WE'VE GOT THE
TECHNOLOGY I CAN WORK WHEREVER
I WANT US WHO DOES NOT WANT TO
IS RIGHT SO WE'VE GOT ALL OF
TYPICAL TRADITIONAL
TRANSACTIONS THAT TAKE PLACE
OF PEOPLE GETTING MARRIED OR
DIVORCED TONIGHT RIGHT. SO ALL
OF THAT IS FUELING OUR
SHORTAGE AT THE MOMENT. BUT
A BUYER WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE.
WE'VE GOT NOW NOW WILL PRICES
CONTINUE TO GO UP FROM SO IT'S
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN LIKE WE DO
EXPECT THAT AT LEAST YOU KNOW
TO BE A 12 TO 18 MONTHS, MOST
ECONOMISTS ARE LOOKING AT
AROUND 2 TO MAYBE MORE YEARS
BUT IF THERE ARE 2 FACTORS TO
CONSIDER WE'VE GOT TO LOOK AT
NEW HOME CONSTRUCTION MAKING
UP THOSE NUMBERS WILL THAT'S
GOING TO HELP. THE OTHER THING
IN FACT OUR VIEWERS CAN REALLY
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS IS. SO IF
YOU HAVE MORE THAN ONE
PROPERTY OR OTHER OPTIONS TO
TO LOOK AT CELL NOW AND PUT IT
ON THE MARKET YOU BE ABLE TO
HELP WE'VE GOT ABOUT 30
SECONDS OR WHAT ABOUT
FORECLOSURES AND FORECLOSURES
GOING OUT WHAT HE WANTS WITH
SITUATION FORECLOSURE RIGHT
NOW THE MARKET SO COUPLE
UNITS THAT WERE AVAILABLE.
MOST OF THOSE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GET MODIFIED WITH THE BANK
ON E AND SO THE REMAINDER
AMOUNT OR ANY OF THOSE
PORTIONS IF THEY CHOOSE TO SO
ARE ALREADY GOING TO HAVE
EQUITY WHICH MEANS IT'S GOING
TO SHOW UP AS A TRADITIONAL
SALE, NOT GOING TO SEE THAT IN
THE MARKETPLACE AND IF THEY DO
DON'T COUNT ((ON GETTING A DEAL
WITH WAS THIS GREAT
INFORMATION WE APPRECIATE YOU
COMING ON AND GIVING US THE
UPDATE. THANK ALL RIGHT, THANK
YOU BLASIO IS ROADIE FOR
SPONSORING THE SEGMENT CALL
THIS IS GREAT AT A SPECIAL